I'm joined today by Anthony Magna Bosco
who is a skeptic who has spoken with
hundreds of people using something
called Street epistemology let's start
with an example of Anthony's work take a
look you have experiences you tribute
those to your god
and what do you think he must want to do
with the same sort of miracles and
experiences they added and what do you
think the Hin you might do if we created
your God very yeah
is the hard percent the right spot to be
if that's really the case on the
confidence of your belief
I really thought I'd leave
thank you so very much I really
appreciate your time so Anthony I mean
the tough thing when you're doing this
this when you're having these types of
conversations with people trying to get
them to examine how they arrived the
beliefs that they have is people very
often get either defensive or
argumentative which by and large doesn't
seem to happen in many of the videos
I've seen of you doing this so how did
you develop your method that you apply
here well I wish that I can take credit
for it it actually originated from a
book called a manual for creating
atheist by dr. Peter Bogosian which I
believe you had on the show yeah your
show at one point and I read the book
and I thought I have to go out and try
this so I did so three years ago I went
out and started having conversations
with people and I started learning that
this more gentle reflective approach
called Street epistemology for
one-on-one conversations was definitely
definitely seemed effective when helping
a person examine the method they used to
arrive at their belief without causing
them to get defensive without causing
them to argue with you and like that
example showed it was a very friendly
back-and-forth and by the end of the
talk you can see he was really thinking
about why he held this belief yeah he
was although he seemed to still stick to
the original belief so I guess I'm
curious what do you know about how
frequently people will actually end up
with drastically different conclusions
and of course a lot of it might happen
long after the conversation you have
with them right I mean how do you expect
success of these conversations and is
the goal even to convert people's views
those are all great questions that I
honestly don't I'm still trying to wrap
my head around what those answers are I
don't really know what a success looks
like yet I don't really know how we can
measure a success
in that instance with that young man at
the end of a talk even though he paused
for thirty or thirty seconds or so to
think about do I really cannot really be
a hundred percent sure that this God
exists yeah
hehe but he basically confirmed that he
was still holding the belief but what we
found from the thousands of people that
are starting to use this method that
oftentimes people are not changing their
minds on camera or in front of you the
change usually happens when they're
alone with their thoughts and are
thinking back on the conversation and I
think if they're being honest with
themselves if they really think about
the methods they use to conclude that
the belief is true and they they realize
that I don't have a reliable method to
know that this thing is true
they will almost certainly lower their
confidence in the belief I wish I had an
answer for you that's one thing that we
want to try to move towards is is
developing like getting the word out for
one thing so that people watching this
video might say this is exactly what
I've been looking for this is what I
want to research because we want to know
if this technique is ineffective or not
there's this guy named Ray Comfort who
I'm guessing you're familiar with who
does sort of the opposite of what you do
which is he goes to the streets and he
asks often incomplete or questions that
lack significant context to try to
convince people about how obviously a
personal Christian God exists what do
you see as the main difference between
sort of street evangelism and Street
epistemology obviously I think we can
all sort of notice the difference in
terms in terms of the sort of subject
matter the approach of the person asking
the question but in terms of its
underlying principles what is the real
difference in terms of what you're doing
and it seems like you're opening views
versus trying to narrow and focus them
is that right yeah it seems like you've
kind of summed that up you're right so
even though the word Street is industry
to piste Amala G there's a common
misconception that we're just as bad as
the evangelizers that are out there and
if you were to watch just watch one or
two videos watch the whole thing through
and I think you'll notice that very
rarely would we tell somebody what to
think or proclaim that we have the truth
and let me correct you on your worldview
so that I can I can steer you the right
way that's not at all what's going on in
these conversations
these conversations are largely based on
me asking questions tell me what you
think tell me why you think it how can
you be so sure that it's true the beauty
of these types of conversations where
Street epistemology is happening is I
never tell anybody what to think or I
should very rarely be doing it because
I'm interested in learning how you've
concluded that it's true and that back
and forth that that Socratic questioning
back back and forth with a person seems
to help a person reflect on how they
form the belief in a way that doesn't
cause them to be defensive and when you
watch a street evangelist engaging with
an atheist for example or somebody else
in the street or even a different
believer who just disagrees on the
doctrine they're often very contentious
and I think that's probably one of them
one of the things you might notice right
away is that the conversations are so
friendly what is not an effective method
for doing what you do I mean is it that
being less friendly approach that's part
of it but one of the main things that
set Street epistemology is apart from
even debating even if you were an
atheist going out to debate a believer
or I am I think that global manmade
climate change is is real and I go out
and try to talk to people and present
facts what we're learning what we're
learning from the scientific community
is that presenting people with facts in
a one-on-one situation that contradicts
their belief is more than likely going
to cause them to double down on their
belief and believe it even more sure so
Street epistemology is a complete end
run around that it we wrote astray
epistemology is based on the hypothesis
that people's beliefs are very tightly
conflated with their self so when I
challenge a belief that you might have
with facts more than likely you might
see that as an affront to your own
identity
well it seems in my particular with
religion right because I say I mean I
think with religion in particular many
people have such a their entire
worldview and identity is heavily tied
up in whatever their religion may be so
I think that what
you're saying about by challenging your
beliefs you're challenging your sense of
self it's particularly true with
religion isn't it very much so what we
found is that these deeply held beliefs
now if I'm having a conversation with
somebody about and I heard this example
on a recent podcast whether you prefer
paper or plastic bags when you grocery
shop in a one-on-one conversation I
might actually be able to provide you
with facts to convince you that the
method that you're choosing is not the
best for the environment you might be
open to it
but if it's political if it's religious
if it's tied to who you are you are more
than likely going to become more
defensive if I were to present you with
facts but if I were to present you with
questions about how you arrived at your
belief which is what's true to pistolas
the street epistemology is all about
what method did you use to conclude that
the belief is true that's the moment
where people seem to be able to set
aside the belief and inspect it with me
together we actually set this up the
belief aside and we're both there
working together to figure it out and
that's where I think that's what I think
sets Street epistemology apart from most
other debates that you might see on
YouTube for example other than watching
the videos of Street epistemology it's
like you who who let you wreck you what
what authors or what text might you
recommend people in our audience who are
interested in this read in order to
familiarize themselves with sort of both
the underlying principles and some of
the techniques that you employ mmm so
the manual a manual for Craig atheists
is the book by dr. Peter Budaj and I
would definitely recommend everybody
picked that up he also created an app
recently called a COS which goes on your
phone Android or Apple stores
motivational interviewing would be good
if you have an interest in in cognitive
behavioral therapy might be good these
are areas where I'm not even an expert
and I don't want to get so bogged down
in the academia of it because I read
Peters book I started going out and
doing it and I committed myself to
learning it and I think I've become
fairly proficient at it I don't have any
special abilities I didn't go to school
to learn this I just
I just been educating myself and there's
more resources out there available for
people today more than ever
can you talk about if there if there are
any such incidents where you didn't get
a good reaction from the person that you
were talking to where things maybe got
dicey and sort of what to what took
place oh yeah yeah that's happened
occasionally but what I found is that
when I find myself encountering somebody
that's so confident in their position
that they're unwilling to open
themselves up to the possibility
possibility that they might be mistaken
that's when I can I can feel my heart
racing and I'm kind of getting more
angry and I feel like I want to start
debating them when I spoke back to my
old ways because I used to go out and
debate with people I had videos where
I'm arguing with street preachers it
doesn't get you anywhere so I have had
those encounters and those examples are
on my channel so that you can you can
literally see the progression of how
more - how much more effective I think
I've become but yeah those happen but
those are few and far between I think
these days if I'm going out and using
Street epistemology very rarely does a
person get upset they're almost always
happy to have had the conversation they
want to talk again when can we please
talk again or I've got this other belief
that I hold when can we talk about that
what's the broader goal I mean obviously
you can only talk to so many people only
portion of those are really going to be
truly open-minded only a portion of
those will end up actually changing
their beliefs what's the broader goal
here well my broader goal is to record
these conversations that normally just
happen organically okay most people that
use Street epistemology just find
themselves in these scenarios and
they're having a conversation with
somebody the hold of belief I'd like to
record the conversations and upload them
to my youtube channel so other people
can see that right like if I didn't do
that we might not be speaking here today
so at the risk of it looking staged or
that I'm initiating these conversations
which I am I think it's important for
other people to see it so that they're
more comfortable mimicking mimicking it
and learning it so as far as the goal
personally I want to live in a world
where people believe things that are
true that people see it as a virtue to
question to doubt til to to say I don't
know when they don't know and and I
think the world will be a better place
if we got to that point so personally
that's my goal and I think a lot of
people that are industry to pista mala
ji movement for lack of a better word
probably feel the same way we've been
speaking with Anthony Magna Bosco you
can check out his Street epistemology go
to youtube.com and just search for his
name Anthony Magna Bosco and you will
have no shortage of videos to do to
watch Anthony thanks so much for talking
to us about this super interesting is
really my pleasure being on your show
Thanks